hi everyone my name is sasha glovinov
and
i would like to present our recent uh
result with sasha quilikov and ryan
williams on circuit depth reductions
in this work we do not prove new circuit
lower bounds
but we give a new framework for a new
way
of proving circuit lower bounds or
formula lower bounds
in particular we'll show that
improvements on the currently known
pseudorandom objects would lead via
our framework to new circuit lower bonds
all right so the outline of the stock is
the phone first i'll introduce the
computational models we're going to be
working with
the model of boolean circuits and the
model of a boolean formulas
and then i'll present a couple of hour
circuit depth
reductions and in particular i'll
explain how to use them to prove
new circuit lower bounds finally i'll
explain i will show
how similar how i achieve similar
results for boolean formulas
okay so boolean circuits and formulas
say we want to compute a function from n
bits to one bit
by a straight line program straight line
program means
we run a variate one command after
another one
without any branchings we don't have if
statements we don't have loops no
branchings at all
such a program is called a straight line
program and it
can also be always written as a
directed acyclic graph duck and such a
duck
is called a circuit okay
so formally we have n inputs x1 x2 xn we
also have this constants zero and one
in gates and the nodes of this uh
graph we can we compute any function of
two
boolean variables and we do not pose any
restrictions on the out degree of the
fan out of the gates
okay so this model of computation is
called boolean circuits
and size of a circuit is a number of
gates in it
in the 40s shannon showed that almost
all functions
uh say a random function sky probability
has a
circuit size at least two to the n over
n
has exponential circuit size and in the
fifties alpha gave
essentially matching upper bound every
function can be computed by a circuit of
size
essentially 2 to the n over n
so we know that most of the functions
have exponential circuit complexity
but the challenge is to find an explicit
heart function
f explicit here means a function from a
reasonable complexity class
so we know that most of the functions
have exponential complexity
but we don't really need exponential
lower bounds even if we find a function
that cannot be computed by polynomial
size circuits we already prove that pde
is not equal to np
if this heart function is from the
complexity class and p
so we know that most functions have
exponential complexity we kind of want
only super polynomial complexity
but the best what we can prove is just
roughly 3n
even if we consider a much much larger
class of
functions that uh e to the np
exponential time with an np oracle
even there the best lower bound we can
prove the best circuit lower bound we
can prove for such functions
is roughly 3n
all right but we have many candidates
for super linear circuit lower bounds
say we know how to multiply two integers
by circuit of size and log n
and many people conjecture that this
should be tied that
we should be able to prove a much lower
amount we just don't have tools for
proving such lower bounds
same with the discrete fourier transform
we know how to compute it by circuit of
size and log n
and probably this is optimal but we
again we don't know how to prove
much in much in lower part for many
shifts and permutations of the n input
bits
we also conjecture super linear circuit
lower bounds we just don't know how to
prove them
finally if you pick your favorite
np-hard problem
then most likely to it requires circuits
of super linear size
so we have many many candidates for
super linear circuit lower bonds we just
don't have tools for preventers
here's what we can prove though if your
circuit has depth 2
then this is essentially a cna for dnf
and this is
more or less the only circuit model
which we understand quite well
here we know that even the parity
function requires circuits of the
largest size of size 2 to the end
so here we're like very good at proving
circuit lower bounds
if circuits have depth 3 4 or any any
constant z
then still we do know how to prove
exponential
circuit lower bounds
for circuits of depth 1.9 log n for
where every gate has funding 2 has in
degree 2
again we know functions that cannot be
computed by the circuits
but already for depth tool again we know
nothing better than a lower bounded
circuit
size or amount of roughly 3m
okay so even for the depth tool again
nothing on trivial is no
so natural problem on the frontier right
now is to prove
a non-trivial even like linear lower
bound for
uh circuits of logarithmic depth
more generally our goal now is to prove
a super linear circuit lower bound for
log
log depth circuits
okay so why can't we prove
interest and circuit lower bounds for
proving lower bounds against um
these unbounded depth circuits the only
known technique is gate elimination
and this technique is just actually an
ugly case analysis we don't want to do
this
and moreover now we know that
this technique cannot prove interest and
circuit lower balance it cannot lead to
circuit lower bounds better than say 5n
but for log depth circuits
balant in 1977 gave us a
wonderful tool uh for proven circuit
lower bounds again we don't know how to
proof such
circuit lower bounds but at least for
log depth circuits we have
a non-trivial and interesting uh
way of attacking this problem
so now let me sketch valence result
valiant says that if you have a function
that can be computed by a linear size
log depth circuit then
it can also be computed by a depth 3
circuit
where the top or has
subexponential in degree 2 to the n over
log log n
then we have level of ends and the
bottom ores
have in degree and to the epsilon
okay so now if you find the functions
that cannot be computed by
such a depth 3 circuit then you also get
a super linear
circuit lower bound for log depth
circuits
all right that's a structural result
of wayland for log depth circuits
so let me put it in the context we want
to prove
a lower bound of two to the n log log n
for depth three circuits and this would
lead for
to a super linear uh lower bound for log
depth circuits
the best what we currently can prove is
slightly smaller than two to the uh n
over log log n but we know
really many ways of proving a lower
bound of two to the n to the 1 minus
epsilon so hopefully one day we'll
improve it
also if the bottom degree
was constant rather than enter the
epsilon we could prove
even stronger depths three lower bonds
two to the linear n
and again we know several ways of doing
this so we know
several ways of proving slightly weaker
results and improvements
on them who would lead to super linear
circuit lower bounds
against log depth circuits
via valence
approach
okay so the result of valent takes a log
depth circuit
and reduces it to depth three and says
now prove a lower one for depth three
circuits objects that we understand
better
and then we'll transfer this result to
log depth circuits
all right so the proof of valence though
it looks
at it views a circuit as a graph
it never looks at what is computed at
any gate as a circuit
and it is known that such graph
theoretic results
cannot be generalized to circuits of
depths
larger than log n
valence approach works really well for
locked up circuits but it probably
cannot work
for circuits of super logarithmic depth
our first result is a similar depth
reduction
but for circus of unbounded depth
unfortunately currently it only works
for circuits of small size
but unbounded depth
all right uh let me show you a tour
example how such a result
for unbounded devs can in principle be
proven
that's just a toy example say i want to
say that
any circuit unbounded depth circuit of
size
s whereas think of it as i don't know
three and four and say
maybe 3.5 and
can be computed by an or
of exponentially many formulas each of
some
small size formula
is a circuit where our degree of
every node is just one
okay formulas are much
easier to work with than circuits so
this result says that you can start with
a circuit and
rewrite it as an or of exponentially
many but much simpler things formulas
in a minute i will explain you why such
a structural result
may be of maybe of interest how to use
it to prove circuit
robots for now let's prove this
to a lemma i want to say any circuit of
cells s can be computed by an
or of in degree 2 to the s over 3
of small formulas
how do i prove it i look at my circuit
size s
so say this is circuit c
of size s and i find
the topologically first gate
that can be that has our degree two here
it will be say this gate g
it has our degree greater greater than
one
since this is topologically first gate
it means that whatever g computes is a
formula because all previous gates
had our degree one so
they were computed by formula g can be
computed
by formulas that's important and now i
want to look at two circuits
the first circuit is my original circuit
c way instead of g
i have zero where g com
evaluates to zero if i have zero here
then i don't really need this gate
i don't need this or of zero and
something
because all of zero and something is
just like the previous the previous gate
i can directly
wire the previous gate to zero and
similarly i don't need this gate because
it's
xor of zero n input so this just input
so the circuit c zero where g compute
zero
is three gates smaller than the circuit
c
similarly circuit c one where g computes
one
a smaller by three gates as well i don't
need the
g and i don't need two consecutive
gates either
okay so i have two circuits c0 and c1
and they both are
smaller by three eighths than the
original circuit
then i say whatever my original
circuit computes can be written the
following way if this gate
g is 0 it's my way
of saying if in circuits if g is 0
then i just output what my c0 circuit
outputs
otherwise if g is one
then i output what a circuit uh
c one outputs and size of both of these
circuits
and size of c1 as well
they're smaller than the size of the
original circuit by at least three gates
therefore some simple and active
argument says that
i will eventually rewrite my original
form
circuit c of x as an or of
two to the s over three
small formulas
all right so this finishes the proof of
this lemma
every uh circuit of size s can be
written as an
or of size 2 to the so3 of small
formulas
uh now how could we use such a result
for circuit lower bounds in principle
imagine that we had a function f
that has small correlation with all
small formulas
small correlation means whatever formula
of linear size i take
it correctly computes my function f only
the half of the inputs plus some sub
sub-exponentially many
inputs that is
any small formula
computes f correctly
only at this many
inputs half of the inputs
plus 2 to the little of n
it's easy to compute my function
correctly on half of the inputs you just
output either zero or one
at least one of this function compute my
function f correctly on half of the
inputs
but i'm saying that any small formula
has small advantage
advantage over this only two to the
little off and
inputs
all right if i had such a function f
then i would have a nice circuit lower
bound
and that each such formula would only
compute
uh f correctly
at like two to the little of an input so
i would have to have
s over three greater than
essentially n minus little of n to
compute my function at
all two to the n points or in other
words i would have a circuit lower bound
of three
and minus little often and we in fact do
know functions that have exponentially
small correlation with
all small formulas just the correlation
is 2 to the
minus epsilon and rather than 2 to the
minus n
so they're not strong enough
moreover applying percival's equation
one i can see that the best correlation
bound
we can hope for is two to the minus
n over two we cannot even hope to get
this correlation
all right but from this you can actually
recover um
circuit lower bound of 1.5 and and a
simple improvement of the
trivial improvement of this argument
gives you a circular bound of 2n
actually
but this this for example they must
demonstrates us how to use such
structural results for circuit
robots and it also shows us
what we need to improve in this story in
this dilemma
first of all if we want to prove circuit
lower bounds better than 3n
then we need to improve this constant 3
because currently it can only lead to
circuit laura bounds three and minus
little of n
and the second thing we want to improve
this formulas we see that formulas
are not sufficient for proven circuit
lower bounds we want to have something
more structured here than just
formulas of small size and in fact the
first result of this paper
achieves this it improves both of these
things first of all it improves the
exponent 3 to 3.9
almost four and uh it also improves the
class of formulas though some small cns
much more structured class of formulas
so our first structural
result says that a circuit of size s can
always be computed
by a depth 3 circuit
where the top fan in top in
in degree is 2 to the s over 3.9
and then we have a small size cnf not
just a
formula but even linear size cnf
very structured formal in other words
yeah we know that a random function most
of the functions cannot be computed by
such depth 3 circuits
and it's not hard to see that
improvements on the
known constructions of dispersers or
correlation with polynomials or depth 3
circuits
would give lower bounds
against this class of circuits and those
where our framework against
unbounded depth servers unbounded depth
therapies as well
all right we also give a similar
structural results for
result for linear circuits uh we say
that
improvements on the currently known
register lower bounds
would give non-trivial circuit lower
bounds against
unbounded depths linear circuits but
i don't wanna i don't wanna
stop on this result now if you are
interested please take a look at our at
our paper
or drop me an email
okay and the remaining time i would like
to
show how we can how we can do
similar depth reductions for formulas
for the morgan formulas
so recall that the morgan formula is a
formula where all gates are ants or some
nodes we don't have say piracy gates
and since this is a formula every out
degree is exactly one
okay a long very beautiful line of work
shows a
formal lower bound of essentially n
cubed
and here our main result uh
gives a framework for proving a
potential later a formal lower bound of
n to the fourth
okay so we say
that first of all under air conjecture
i will explain what uh this conjunction
in a minute under some conjecture
every demorgan formula of size
almost n to the fourth can be
approximated
by a real sum of
sub-exponential size
of f2 polynomials of uh
sublinear degree that is of mods
that is parities modules that is paris
of
ends of sub-linear degree
once again every demorgan formula under
some conjecture
of size almost end to the phone can be
computed by a real
real sum
of sub-exponential size of uh
f2 polynomials of sub-linear degree
all right so first of all this this
theorem currently only holds under some
conjecture but
we believe that this conjecture is kind
of plausible
and second in order to get
actual demorgan formal lower bounds we
need functions
that cannot be computed by such depth
three circuits
we know that a random function cannot be
computed by such a beast
and we have some partial the
randomization results
we know that uh we know more explicit
functions that cannot be computed by
a weaker versions of these depths
circuits
so currently we were using
an unproven conjecture and we don't yet
have a provable function that is a
function that is probably hard against
the depth three circuits of this form
but nevertheless let me present this
depth reduction
so how do we prove lower bounce against
the computational model usually we say
that
everything compute everything computable
by this computational model
it has some structure and here is a
function that doesn't have the structure
hence a lower bound right but we don't
really
understand uh circuits of formal as well
we are much better
in working with low degree polynomials
those who understand much better
so ideally would like to say that
everything computable by a small circuit
can also be computed by
something like log polynomial and then
would present a function that cannot be
computed by a low degree polynomial and
conclude a
lower bound but this approach doesn't
really work because say
the or function has tiny formals of
linear size
but requires polynomials of highest
degree of linear degree
so this doesn't this simple approach
doesn't really work
but when exact polynomials don't work
we use either randomized or probability
or approximate
versions of like whatever polynomials
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
uh in this result we can't say that
whatever um
small formula computes has a low degree
polynomial
because even or even the or function is
a counter example
but we can say something similar with
randomized and approximate
versions of polynomials so first let me
remind you what we mean by
approximate and randomized polynomials
in this case
if i have a function from n bits to one
bit
then an approximate polynomial for this
function is a polynomial
over the reals this is very important
this polynomial is over the reals
that approximately computes uh this
function f at every point
that is for every input the difference
between
this polynomial and the function is less
than one third
so this polynomial p it
always tells apart zeros of f from one
surface
just at zero it can output maybe one
third at one
it can it can output two thirds but
there is always a gap between that
okay so this is what approximate
polynomials are
now um and yeah and we'll use this
beautiful result by rekhard
that says that every function from n
bits to one bit can be compu that has a
de morgan formula says s
can also be computed by an approximate
polynomial of degree square root of
s
now probabilistic polynomials if i have
a function again from n bits to one bits
to one bit then a probabilistic
polynomial
is a distribution of polynomials over f2
such that for every input a random
polynomial correctly computes
uh the value of my function and this
input with all but negligible
probability
so probabilistic polynomials is the
distribution of polynomials over f 2
such that for every input a random
polynomial gives the correct answer
with probability one minus epsilon
okay approximate polynomials are over
the reals probabilistic polynomials are
over f2
now the conjecture that we're going to
be using uh
which we believe is plausible uh
is the following every demorgan formula
of size s has
a probabilistic polynomial that's
polynomial over f2
of degree square root of s or some
constant
and some reasons to think
that this conjecture might hold as a
full line every demorgan formula has
approximate polynomials over the reals
of this degree of degree square root of
s
also all symmetric functions do have
probabilistic polynomials of degree
square root of s
also all the morgan formulas that i kind
of layered like
end of horse of ends of force of ends of
force they do have a
probabilistic polynomial of degree
square root of s
um those are the main reasons why we
believe this may hold for all the morgan
formulas and from now on
[Music]
like let's use this uh
let's use this conjecture to prove our
main result okay
so the main result for formulas is a
following take a formula of size and to
the four minus some epsilon two epsilon
uh we'll rewrite it as a sum
of f two polynomials sum is uh some have
the sum has
sub-exponential size and those um f two
polynomials have sub-linear degree
okay so first of all
every formula is a tree and
trees can always be balanced in various
nice ways
in particular it is known that the
demorgan formula can
also be balanced in the following way so
i can
rewrite every demorgan formula of size n
to the 4 minus 2 epsilon
as a top part of size square root
of 8 that is of size n to the 2 minus
epsilon
and all bottom formulas all small
formulas
will be also size square root of that is
of size n to the 2 minus epsilon
okay so every formula says n to the 4
minus 2 epsilon can be rewritten as a
top formula size
and to the 2 minus epsilon of small
formulas each of the same size
all right now i'll apply
i'll rewrite the top part of the formula
as an approximate polynomial over the
reals
by the result of record this approximate
polynomial has degree square root of s
that is n to the 1 minus like
epsilon over 2 or 1 minus epsilon
okay so a real polynomial of this degree
means is just
sum of products
and the degree of each product is
sublinear and to the
one minus epsilon over two okay and now
we apply our conjecture to each
blue formula to each formula at the
bottom
by our conjecture each such formula has
a probabilistic polynomial over f2
of degree square root of s
that is it can be written as a parity of
ends
each end of degree n to the 1 minus
epsilon over 2
1 minus epsilon doesn't matter all right
so at the top i have real polynomials
of degree square root of s at both in
the bottom i have uh
i have two polynomials of degree um
square root of s2 now
i will hit the top real polynomial with
the recent result of shortstop
with robust polynomials robust
polynomial says that
if i have a real polynomial
that takes inputs like zeros and ones
then i have another real polynomial of
essentially same degree
that even if the inputs are shifted by a
little bit by small constants like
every input is shifted by at most one
third
new polynomial of essentially the same
degree computes the correct result
computes whatever the original real
polynomial computed
so it allows us to make little
a little error in every input i hit the
top real polynomial with this robust
robust polynomial's result bachelor
stove
and now for the bottom blue polynomials
i just i have a probabilistic polynomial
polynomials
i have a distribution of f two
polynomials now i sample
linear number of such polynomials and
take the average of them
by some turn of bound this tells me
that um every output
will be wrong only with small constant
probability say like one third
so now but sure enough if i take average
of a bunch of such polynomials
then the result is results are good
enough
for this robust polynomials because
each output here is wrong only by at
most one third
so now in the top i have sum of products
in the bottom i have sum of
parishes of ants
here is what i have sum of products of
sum of
pieces of ants now i'll apply
the distributivity law to product of
sums i can always rewrite it as some
huge sum of products
so here's what i have now now note that
this product
takes zeros of zeros or ones
such a product is also known as and if
all the inputs
are zero so once i can rewrite it as a
boolean function end
now every boolean function can be
written in the fourier basis
that is it can always be written
as a sum of parities
and that's exactly what i'm doing here
instead of this end
i'll write sum of parities
finally i'll just collapse this sum of
sum of sum and i'll collapse this mod of
mod
this will give me subexponential sum
of f2 polynomials of sublinear degree
that's exactly the result we wanted to
prove
under our conjecture every demorgan
formula of size
almost n to the four can be rewritten as
a sub-exponential
real sum of f-two polynomials of
sub-linear db
all right that that finishes this proof
and in fact this finishes my talk i'll
just wanted to
end this talk with a slide with
summary of
[Music]
what improvements of pseudo-random
results are needed for new circuit lower
bonds
via variant
or our frameworks
that's it and uh thank you for watching
this talk